I'm here today in Manhattan talking to
dr. Jonathan hight who's a professor at
NYU and I have him here for a bunch of
reasons Jonathan is an extremely
interesting researcher I've been
following his work on discussed and
political belief for literally four
decades it was one of the first people
who started to do serious research on
disgust which is its own emotional
system and therefore very much worth
attending to but we also have some other
interests in common Jonathan also
started this Institute called the
heterodox Academy which is attempting to
bring back a reasonable diversity of
views or what he regards as a reasonable
diversity of views to university faculty
and campuses and discussions so I first
met Jonathan it's gonna be just about 30
years ago 25 years ago in 2014
yeah twindom site the 1994 oh it was in
1994 yeah yeah right right so yeah you
came to do a job talk at Harvard - yeah
for an assistant professorship position
and I had been aware of your work on
discussed then and and agitated hard for
them to hire you because I thought it
was of great significance which turned
out to be exactly the case so what do
you remember about that I remember I was
so excited to have an interview at
Harvard it was my only interview I
didn't get that job I had no job for the
following year and it was a very strange
day in which I didn't feel particularly
welcomed or wanted and then I had my
session with you in which it was this
guy who was it had a he actually got a
job at Harvard and he was studying young
which is like almost taboo and he was
talking about dreams of creativity and
so I just that was the really bright
that was the bright memory of the day
was our hour-long conversation